ja es geht um angela merkel ich glaube
viele haben eben auch den wirklich
bewegen den abschied gesehen den
zapfenstreich zur verabschiedung ihres
16-jährigen bundeskanzler schafft und
wenn man sich natürlich vorstellt dass
ich jetzt nach 16 jahren die tür des
kanzlers haben die sind ihr schließt
dann geht die ära zu ende und man wird
dann schon wehmütig ich glaube wir haben
hier wirklich sehr sehr viel zu
verdanken sie hat es geschafft auch
deutschland ein großes ansehen in der
welt zu geben durch ihr auftreten durch
ihr verhandeln durch ihr taktieren auch
mit den größten der welt sie hat es
geschafft durch ihre sachliche
kompetente art und weise auch durch die
vielen krisen die in den 16 jahren
gewesen sind deutschland gut
durchzuringen oftmals besser als unsere
nachbarländer und dafür gilt ihr einfach
der dank und ich war viele viele jahren
durfte ich kollegin von ihr seien
insgesamt 13 jahren von meinen vor meine
tränen jahr oder sogar länger länger ja
aber viele viele jahre und ich habe sie
kennengelernt als eine hart arbeitende
frau eine hat abende kanzlerin der
wirklich das wohl das land ist immer an
erster stelle gestanden ist wo alles
hinten dran gestanden war die perfekt
vorbereitet war besser vorbereitet als
jegliche fachpolitiker die oft in den
gremien waren sie immer es standen hat
ein kompromiss zu suchen oft auch zu
finden manchmal natürlich auch nicht zu
finden aber danke zu sagen und ich solle
ihr respekt für die vielen vielen jahren
und ich bin froh dass wir sie gehabt
haben und sind jetzt sehr sehr große
fußstapfen
also heute sehr der abend des
zapfenstreichs ein abend im netz zu sein
ja aber ich mache mich jetzt unbeliebt
und für was wird angela merkel denn in
den geschichtsbüchern stehen da ist zum
einen mal der atomausstieg heute wissen
wir es wäre wohl schlauer gewesen erst
aus der kohle auszusteigen dann aus der
atomenergie da ist die
flüchtlingspolitik die hat die afg
überhaupt erst möglich gemacht da hat
angela merkel doch ehrt island gewirkt
da gilt jetzt osteuropa gegen westeuropa
dann ist die euro-rettung zugegeben da
wissen wir nicht ob es nicht hätte noch
schlimmer ausgehen können völlig klar
aber die hat uns die geldpolitik
beschert die uns mittlerweile zum teil
zumindest auch diese inflation besteht
dann natürlich das thema corona brauchen
nicht darüber reden und last but not
least sie hat ihre eigene partei völlig
inhaltsleer überlassen sie steht mit dem
rücken an der wand sie bekommt jetzt in
dritten vorsitzenden innerhalb kurzer
zeit also sich die macht verloren ich
kenne frau merkel einen tollen ganz
ehrwürdigen zapfenstreich aber das erbe
ist doch ein bisschen durchmischt ja das
will ich einen jungen mann der nicht
dabei war was damals passiert war nicht
aber die situation ist manchmal ein
bisschen anders wie sie vielleicht
manchmal von außen scheint muss man
sehen sie hat es wirklich geschafft mit
dem lissabon-vertrag europa auf beine zu
stellen ich habe sie in vielen vielen
heißen erlebt wo ich mit ihr auch
unterwegs gewesen ist ich habe mir die
eu ratspräsidentschaft damals auch als
staatssäckel mitgemacht ich weiß wie sie
verhandelt hat und wie sie es geschafft
hat auch
zerstrittene parteien zusammen zu
bekommen sie hat es wirklich verstanden
sich in die einzelnen staatsmänner
hineinzudenken sie wusste immer die
einzelnen probleme der staatsmänner fort
sie wusste auch wie weit sie gehen
können sie wusste immer bis wohin auch
ein kompromiss geht
es gibt immer situationen wo man nachher
viel glück ist aber vor sie sind
unionspolitikerin
in welchem zustand hat sie die union
hinterlassen also die union hat ist
vollkommen inhaltlich entkernt und
niemanden wir können heute wirklich
sagen wofür die cdu steht und davon
dafür ist sie die hauptverantwortliche
sie hat es auch nicht geschafft einen
einen einen nachfolger aufzubauen das
ist ja bei großen dominanten politiker
nämlich so also bei franz josef strauß
war das aber war das ähnlich auch bei
helmut kohl aber ich finde dass ich
filme interessant dass sie am ende
wahrscheinlich gar keine unions
politikerin war sondern solange
kanzlerin war dass sie am ende
vielleicht so etwas wie eine
überparteiliche kanzlerin war aber sie
war immer auch lange zeit cdu
vorsitzende ich finde das ist ein großes
versäumnis ich weiß nicht weiß dass
jemand von euch wie viel an cdu jetzt
steht was dann thema war es vor allen
dingen die these unterstreicht beim
letzten sommer interview hat es ja auch
noch gesagt die cdu eine partei die mir
sehr nahe steht ich glaube das
unterstreicht wie sehr sie sich doch
entfernt hat den letzten beiden jahren
jetzt erst mal fragen wir uns gerade
gesagt alexander überparteiliche
kanzlerin das erwarte ich von meinem
kanzlei sich hoffe dass jetzt auch
urlaub scheut sich irgendwann sagen
werde er hat nicht nur alles für seine
eigene partei gemacht sondern für die
bürger für die gesellschaft es ist ja
sein das ist interessant ich hab' ich
glaube dass das bei manchen
bundeskanzlerin so ist also ich glaube
auch helmut schmidt war am ende kein spd
haben mehrere da war am ende ja jetzt
kein spd-mann oder das ist interessanter
ist es so dass große kanzler am ende den
kontakt zu ihrer partei verlieren und
überparteilich werden das könnte man als
tugend sehen aber mein vater war auch
cdu abgeordneter ich muss sagen ich habe
immer große sympathie für die cdu gehabt
aber ich wüsste heute geht und wie viel
mir kein grund ein die cdu zu wählen ist
vielmehr auch jetzt nicht ein wenn wir
jetzt in drei sachen sagen wo das wofür
die cdu steht fällt mir nichts ein ich
hab gestern
entlasten indem man zu gast kann seit
der antworten auf ich weiß es nicht
vielleicht ist der kongo wächst etwas
nach in der cdu ich sehe so moment nicht
ja also es ist doch klar dass das die
union steht als auf jeden fall mal für
eigenverantwortung ich glaube es gibt
keine partei die so viel
eigenverantwortung steht für die union
sie steht aber vier subsidiarität fürs
gemeinwohl es gibt viele punkte die man
hier mit aufzählen kann und ich glaube
es wird seit langem wird lange dauern
bis wir wieder so eine außenpolitikerin
auch bekommen werden wie angela merkel
nicht umsonst ist ja auch von der times
hier benannt wollen auch die führerin
der freien welt oder als als der
politikerin des jahres
aber es ist auch unser standing in der
welt hat sie wirklich geschäft vor allem
ich weit auch natürlich auch mit
entwicklungs zusammenarbeit mit der
außenpolitik viel im ausland unterwegs
und ich habe diese anerkennung die man
ihr gezeugt hat und die manier zollt die
hat sich natürlich auch auf uns aus
deutschland abgefärbt das war
schlichtweg www bicol damit gewesen ist
muss man sagen überall wo er hinkam war
natürlich bei uns war schon das thema
die wahl verloren gehabt 98 muss man
dazu sagen aber in der welt der ware
immer noch anerkannt und eine der
größten politischen männer da gestand
aber das ist doch das spannende bei
angela merkel dass dieses missverhältnis
aus ihrer wahrnehmung gerade im
intellektuellen sphären des auslands
also ja ostküsten intellektuelle in den
usa halten sie für die führerin der
freien welt aber im schatten von donald
trump das muss man natürlich dazu sagen
hat sie diese rolle eingenommen aber das
passt ja überhaupt nicht zu ihrer beute
an zu arbeiten so lange mit an bord naja
aber der kontrast hat er das dass diese
diese rede inhaber die sie gehalten hat
das war ja der höhepunkt ihrer
außendarstellung so sagen das passt
natürlich überhaupt nicht zu dem was
hier im eigenen land erreicht hat
ehrlich gesagt und ich würde auch sagen
europa ist jetzt nach 16 jahren merkel
auf keinen fall in einem besseren
zustand als vorher und aber wir wissen
auch nicht wie europa noch da stehen
würde ohne angela merkel und was ist
innenpolitisch passiert man muss schon
sagen ihre politik der schwarzen null
hat tonnen für sehr sehr viele
formationen stau geführt und wenn man
jetzt schaut in vielen punkten ist
deutschland abgerutscht ein thema
digitalisierung ist viel zu wenig
passiert in investitionen öffentlichen
nahverkehr aber wenn ich jetzt muss
jetzt muss ich doch sie und wir sprechen
gerade mit digitalisierung also ich bin
jetzt ein paar jahre auch aus der
politik heraus aber ich weiß genau das
sucht in digitalisierungs packt die
gelder sind ja da muss wenn sie die
gelten nicht abgerufen werden von den
ländern und kommunen da können sie eine
angela merkel jetzt keinen vorwurf
machen ja das einfach ein versäumnis
auch in gewissen anderen föderalen
strukturen auch passiert das geld ist ja
da gewesen aber es wurde halt eben nicht
abgerufen aber frau war gerade auch in
gerade im bereich digitalisierung mehr
für jedes thema nur eine gewisse
zeitspanne ich glaube wir können auch
ganz lange aber von einer bürgerin
studieren alles alles gute
danke für 16 jahre dankeschön angela
merkel ich finde auch dass es heute mehr
als angebracht und ich war aber eben
auch ich habe auch sehr viel melancholie
von sie war eine tolle faszinierende
frau und ich vergesse es nie als ich sie
kennengelernt habe als umweltministerin
das war 94 gewesen ich hatte so großen
respekt damals auch vorgehabt als
damals sie sich als umweltministerin wo
diese gegner der castor-transporte
hingestellt alle männer sind auf die
seite gegangen sie war die einzige die
standhaft stehen geblieben ist und sich
mit einer hat damit bewerben und ihre
tolle frau